FRIENDLY VISIT, MATTER REFERRING
PROTOCOL, FIVE OTHERS GOING
AGGRESSIVE.
>> Gord: ZADOROV STEPPED UP TO
KEEP THE PLAY ALIVE, BOUNCING NT
TUESDAY NIGHT IN BOSTON.ARY ON R
PLAY, JOHNNY GAUDREAU WITH A
SHOT, PICKED UP BY TKACHUK.EEDSN
THE CALGARY ZONE.AY.
>> Jamie: BEAUTIFUL GOAL BUT
HE JUMPED INTO THE PLAY BUT FLAE
ZERO SUGAR MORE DELICIOUS.
TASTE IT
VLADAR BACK FOR
KYLINGTON.
>> Jamie: THESE GUYS HAVE B THEY
GUY,O TKACHUK, AWAY
BY LINDHOLM BUT BROUGHT IN BY
I!
VLADAR THE SAVE!
LOOSE PUCK LOOSE
CHANGE, BUT GOOD LOOK
TO KELLY, THAYLINGTON
WITH A HIGH RISK PLAY.
PLAYING WITH A LOT OF
CONFIDENCE, YO HAVE A 1-NOTHING.
>> Gord: ASSUMI TEAM DEBUT
ARTEM ZUB, A SENATORS.
ANDREW MANGIAPANE CONTINUES HIS.
HE WAS AT THE GAME AT THE OTTAWA
RASMUS ANDERSSON JUST FLOATS IT
DOWN TO THE FRONT COURSE CALGARN
MARK G GDREAU WITH A CHANCE.HE .
LINDHOLM BACK THROUGH THE SEAM,
DEL ZOTTO CAN'T CLOSE THAT
MATTHEW TKACHUK CENTRES IT
BEGAN, SABOURIN BACK FOR
ULTIMATELY YOU HAVE TO FIND THE
LEGS TO GET THIS G OFFICIALLY FA
ON THE POWER P PLAY KELLY, LEADO
MATTHEW TKACHUK, GOES IN. LINE-.
THEY'RE STARTI
LOOKED LIKE THE SNOW WENT BESIDE
CHABOT PLAYS
>> Jamie: SOKOLOV HAS HAD